mais vous savez que le week-end dernier
netflix a dévoilé la nouvelle série
américaine tout le monde en a fait des
gorges chaudes en fait la série qu'il
faut absolument voir ça s'appelle mdn
périssent
alors voilà avec un testing franco
américain parlait très bien anglais
valérie oui c'est fou on foncera les
détails tous les deux ça raconte quoi ça
raconte l'histoire évidemment d'une
petite américaine exige une jeune femme
originaire de chicago qui emménage ville
une chambre de bonne voie la petite
soeur de savoir saint palais pour
travailler dans une agence de marketing
et comme par hasard au fil des épisodes
elle va essayer de faire entendre sa
voix mais mais mais ce qui pose problème
dans cette petite émission fin dans
cette petite série c'est que en fait les
français sont offerts les parisiens sont
pas très sympas et paris est un cliché
total regarder
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est nous
la série est faux clichés sur la france
vous avez l'occasion de voir des
épisodes qu'on vous a envoyé parce que
vous travaillez
je suis extraordinaire et vous est-ce
que vous trouvez des chèques de makoun
qui trouvent que c'est trop cliché ça y
est la tanière des lions qui a présidé
un entre-deux entre deux d'accord bien
évidemment c'est bourré de clichés c'est
à dire qu'elle se promène dans la rue
comme par hasard elle marche dans une
crotte
elle a son petit béret paris on a faim
moi j'adore les vagues heure de paris
dans lequel elle vit elle prend pas le
métro elle pourtant le métro les
français sont des gros ego ise gros que
tard d'aider des gens désagréables qui
parle superman aux américains qui parle
très mal américains d'ailleurs quand
enfin pour l'air pour la plupart des cas
ces blindés de clichés après il faut
rappeler que ça a été créée par darren
star c'est qui ces indicateurs de série
et c'est lui qui nomme notamment à fait
sex and the city
we will rock you des clichés sont new
york il a été champion quel dans sex and
the city carrie bradshaw sarah jessica
parker on a essayé de nous faire croire
que la nana avec son salaire de pyj ça
se paye un énorme à parme dans manhattan
et qu'elle un vidéo ça vient encore en
haute couture et lui son explication
c'est à dire ça c'est qui dit je donnais
déjà une vision biaisée de new york va
pas pourquoi j'aurais pas fait la même
chose à paris
donc oui à un amendement de clichés oui
mais voilà c'est totalement assumé je
maillot vous êtes d'accord avec
hemingway je suis d'accord en plus ça
reflète un petit peu ce qui se passe sur
paris c'est on est un peu ronchon on a
un peu truc mais j'aimerais surtout voir
emilie de barbès
[Rires]
allier pas et puis même si oui c'est un
peu dommage je trouve moi je trouve que
c'est un peu dommage parce que c'est des
clichés en trier mais qui sont positifs
abondé cousineau positif attendait
garder ils sont on n'est pas l'ailé fois
les parisiens sont râleurs mal élevé ça
c'est chaque fois qu'on va dans un pays
en est les français râlent ça on est
râleur nous le dira mais on voit la tour
eiffel paris ville de l'amour elle
rencontre l'amour alors émerger une
crotte nos traditions je trouve que ça
te dit tu marches dans une merde ça
porte bonheur
c'est comme nous quand on est cliché du
mur qu'on doit tous avec notre truc de
café notre groupe est maire ils sont
vrais cette fois ci leur nous fait un
nom mais et c'est positif
j'ai moi j'ai regardé premier épisode
j'ai trouvé ça très bien et j'ai trouvé
que c est ça aussi des pêcheurs positif
paris non pas sur la france c'est
l'angoissé me dérange parce qu'on parle
de la france mais en fait pas du tout
les parisiens sont vraiment comme ça les
gens qui viennent du sud qui viennent à
paris pendant toute la série c'est
pareil il trouvait que les parisiens
sont pas sympathiques arrogant mal hervé
je suis d'accord le français bat la
preuve le français il aime bien rocha et
leur bien être
il serait pas le français mais le
parisien président et il ya des
exceptions et le veut exactement